now I know you are raising money for the
film on an equity crowdfunding site and
and you've briefed us a little bit
behind the scenes that there certain
things you can't talk about and forgive
me if I overstep the ballot we stop me
at any moment if something because I'm
used to interviewing people that have
been on kickstarter indiegogo some of
these other sites so what is equity
crowdfunding first and foremost what is
it how is it different from Kickstarter
and IndieGoGo well it's a new law that's
just coming into effect it's only been
around for a year it went into effect in
2016 and it's called regulation
crowdfunding or equity crowdfunding
investment crowdfunding Victor and
before this law came into effect if you
wanted to invest in a start-up like
Facebook or something like that when
they were first starting up legally you
had to be what they call a high net
worth individual you had to be somebody
I believe that you make over $200,000 a
year or however a million dollars in net
worth and that led out that that left
out 90% of the population 90% of
population could not invest in these
only these venture capitalists of these
really wealthy people could do it but
this new law came into effect that
allows other businesses to raise money
to everyone a we can the average person
can invest in something with equity
crowdfunding and you couldn't do that
before and the difference between this
and Kickstarter is when you put money
into an equity crowdfunding project like
ours if you did an Kickstarter they give
you a DVD or a t-shirt or something like
that
this you get a piece of the company if
the movie makes money you make money so
you enjoy the success or failure if
except movie fails of course movies can
always you crash and burn anything to
crash and burn but if it succeeds you go
along for the ride so that's the big
difference a lot of companies are doing
it a lot of microbreweries restaurants
coffee companies they've all
successfully raised millions of dollars
electric cars as a new electric car out
there there's a guy who successfully
raised millions of dollars for a jetpack
the first non-military
jetpack could have yeah it's so cool and
I mean they have the video it's real it
works and you and you can put money into
that company and things like that
there's tampon of the Month Club
oh there's I mean everything you could
possibly imagine there's somebody
starting up a company under this new law
we are the first feature-length
narrative film to raise money this way
in the United States they've been a
couple in Europe you know a couple in
Asia but we're the first ones in America
to do this with a feature-length film
one other company did a collection of
short films but we're the first ones to
do a full-length narrative film and it's
really exciting it's cool because it's
new and nobody's done it so it's really
exciting and we're succeeding it's going
well it is I don't know if you're
allowed I forgive me if I'm overstepping
my bounds we can cut this out but are
you alive I say the dollar amount and
you've done very well since April of
2017 is when you launch the campaign
right yes we're doing well the SEC the
Securities Exchange Commission regulates
this offering it's not like Kickstarter
or anybody can just do it there's a lot
more involved in us making this offering
and they have rules about we can talk
about okay we can't actually talk about
dollar amounts people have to go to the
website and all the information is right
there it's super easy to read and all
that's right there but I can tell you
this for a year previously before we did
the equity cruffin campaign I went
around and talked to rich people people
outside the business who who were
wealthy and I tried to talk to them to
raise money and I raised a little money
to go here in seven weeks I have raised
a hundred and forty percent of what I
raised in a year talking to rich people
Wow so I love equity crowdfunding
because instead of having to convince a
few individuals with money to write a
check you can talk to the whole world
international investors we have
investors from Australia and Europe who
are putting money in anyone can invest
in their
anyone and it's really exciting because
we just have to get the message out to
the crowd and people who get it people
who get the movie that we're doing who
understand it are like oh this is fun
it's an investment too cool so instead
of REIT a story about one investor I
talked I was talking this very wealthy
fellow nice guy we're sitting in
wingback chairs next to his private lake
okay I felt like I was in the movie
Casablanca the Sydney Greenstreet and
I'm pitching him project and he says
well you know this lead character he
read the script and he's not in the
business so he he's not used to reading
scripts he's just reading you know a
flow charts an accounting statements and
profit in LA she but he read this script
and he says you know in the beginning of
this movie I don't like the lead
character she's not very likable I said
yeah but you like her later he goes yeah
I like her by the end I go well that's
the idea is that she changes movies have
an arc where the character starts had a
certain way they go through the story
and if it's an upbeat ending if it's a
comedy than they improved their life
they find love they find success
whatever they find it and we go along
the journey so she changes he goes
mmm-hmm but I don't like her in the
beginning
I said oh right and I explained it again
what an arc was and I'm sure a lot of
your the people were your readers who go
to your site there were a lot of my
writers they understand this in a movie
you change there's an arc so we talked
for 20 minutes like this and he kept
shaking but but I don't like her in the
beginning and finally I said to the guy
I said you know there was a character in
a movie she was very mean she used
people she didn't care about anybody but
herself she was selfish she was
basically just a horrible and she
this character was the lead character
and the highest-grossing film of all
time called gone with the wind and and
this guy was in is like a 70s so he knew
that movie not that he goes he goes Oh
and it was just surreal having this
conversation with this guy here trying
to explain this to him and it wasn't his
business so he didn't understand it
because he didn't get this business
whereas we do the crowdfunding the
equity crowdfunding a lot of people even
if it's not their business they get it
they've thought about it you know they
thought oh that would be fun
and so they get it and it's such a
tremendous reason to get it on our
Facebook page we have a Facebook page
for the movie for that Christmas movie
on Facebook and it's so we kept last
weekend we make a little post about the
movie and who's in it and stuff like
that and we had a sweet little grandma
from Missouri keep she posted this is
great the thumbs up and it was so
heartwarming to see that we've reached
some sweet lady know that we didn't know
in Villanova and she gets us and as
filmmakers and writers that's there's
nothing better than when people get what
you're doing
you